how's it going Internet dudes I'm Walter
benezia
and this is top 5 last week we took a
look at his best and this week guys I
don't even want to do this one I love
this guy man but only one actor has been
exempt from having a worst episode so to
keep with tradition I got to do what I
got to do I'm sorry can you I am in
heavy disagreements with these people
but there are some who would say that
Keanu Reeves has a decently sized back
catalog of bad performances personally I
don't find most of these terrible
counters proved that he has great range
as an actor and when he's on he's
amazing I also think that not every role
he's been cast in has fit his unique
personality and charisma from his
younger days in Dangerous Liaisons two
more recent films like knock-knock there
are roles that many critics and fans
alike just do not enjoy Keanu it which
of these misfires are the most obvious
though these are the top five worst
Keanu Reeves performances number 5 Hever
in Youngblood I'd like to think of this
movie as bode and Utah the younger years
Dean Youngblood is the 17-year old son
of a farmer who was invited to try out
for a Canadian junior hockey team he
makes the team but finds out playing
hockey and Hamilton isn't exactly what
he expected as the season rolls on he
and his teammates try to win the
Memorial Cup and get noticed by NHL
scouts all right we're gonna watch all
of Keanu's lines this movie right here
right now you ready here we go and
that's about all the screen time Cannell
is Canadian and was a goalie in high
school in college apparently he was
helping some of the actors learn the
game on set his french-canadian accent
is a little strange but I mean he's
barely in this I originally had tune in
tomorrow in this spot but after watching
his performance and that again I decided
to go with Youngblood I mean I needed a
number 5 and I just don't think he's
awful in most things the rest of the
movie is a little weird with shaving
balls in general 80s sexual
but it's not a bad sports movie Rob Lowe
and Patrick Swayze are pretty darn good
in it so moving on number four Don John
in much ado about nothing when your
older brother is Denzel Washington it's
not easy to look great in comparison
hero the young daughter of the Machine
e'en governor and Claudio and Erika
knees count are to be Wed however the
night before their wedding an elaborate
ruse leads Claudio and his prince Don
Pedro to believe that hero has been
unfaithful this was set up by Don Pedro
jealous half-brother Don John confusion
hurt feelings and painful accusations
that ensue so Shakespeare and Keanu
Reaves audiences probably didn't see
this one coming at the time although
Keano did do a lot of Shakespeare as a
young actor before appearing in films
even starred as Hamlet in a big stage
play the year after speed was released
well as say it is a little out of place
to see him and much ado about nothing
he's not in it a ton and when he's on
screen he's not that bad as the
villainous Don John I had rather be a
canker in a hedge than a rose in his
grace to see the movie is pretty decent
though I'm not at all a Shakespeare guy
myself but the cast is entertaining and
I love Michael Keaton in this movie top
five Michael Keaton you want to see it
let me know in the comments number three
Johnny and Johnny mnemonic this movie is
super weird but actually has some
worthwhile parts in it johnny is a
mnemonic courier who gets important
information transferred into his head
through an implant he tries to leave the
profession but is convinced to do one
more job it turns out to be way more
than he bargained for as the amount of
information put in his head goes past
his capacity limit now if Johnny doesn't
get rid of the information soon it will
start to bleed into his brain and kill
him I'll admit I kind of liked this
movie for some of the concepts and how
ridiculous it got Keanu was not
consistently bad here but there are a
few questionable lines how about it
Ralphie you said you'd lock down a date
for the procedure
we got parents and stuff
you got parents and stuff I want service
watching this movie is worth it for
Dolph Lundgren alone he's so well just
look sinners Jesus watch Johnny
pneumonic it's a good time number two
Klaatu and The Day the Earth Stood Still
this one was pretty much doomed from the
beginning in this remake of the 1951
classic an alien named Klaatu arrives on
earth to save it from humans after
trying and failing to speak with world
leaders Klaatu befriends a scientist and
her stepson who do all they can to
convince him to stop the destruction
while this is happening they're all on
the run from the government because the
scientist helped Klaatu escape from a
holding facility for a while after the
first matrix came out Keanu was known
for this sort of lifeless performance
it's more frustrating than anything else
we know Keanu is super entertaining we
know he's a very unique star that we
want to see be entertaining having him
do this kind of performance is a waste
of his talents are you human my body is
I know that he's an alien a very stoic
grim alien but they could have let him
add some personality to it Michael
Rennie was charismatic and even likable
as Klaatu in the 50s version I know they
wanted to take another angle on it but
you have one of the most charismatic
actors in the world at your disposal and
this is how you use him there's another
side to you close but no I like nothing
about this movie do yourself a favor and
watch the original from 1951 Klaatu
Barada nikto and the number one worst
Keanu Reeves performance is Jonathan
Harker in Bram Stoker's Dracula I know
kind of obvious Jonathan Harker is a
young solicitor who was sent to
Transylvania and the castle of Count
Dracula to finalize a lane deal
however when Dracula sees a picture of
Jonathan's fiancee Mina who looks
exactly like his wife from 400 years
earlier he keeps Harker at his castle
and travels to London to
and make her his broth the movie is a
mixed bag for sure but kyon all just
doesn't fit I really respect how far
director Francis Ford Coppola went to
make this movie look like it did there
are some breathtaking shots effects and
sequences in this film and everything
was done in camera with a lot of old
silent film era tricks there's a lot
about as I like Gary Oldman is amazing
Anthony Hopkins is great and they even
like Winona Ryder but the one thing that
sticks out
[Music]
Keanu's London accent is widely known as
one of the worst accents in movie
history and yeah it's not good bloody
wolves chasing me through some blue
inferno I know where the Boston sleeps -
coughs what does this make him a bad
actor overall he'll know lay off haters
his career is filled with great movies
and performances this just wasn't one of
them for more content over on my
personal channel a John wick versus
taken video is up which is the better
older guy revenge flick find out you
know I feel really bad about doing this
list
I love Keanu Reeves how can I make it up
to him
[Music]
hitting the ways because I'm learning
surf yeah I'm learning to surf in the
ocean fall off my board because I'm
gonna be surfing learning to surf and
it's hurting my friends I they sent a
painless ways
catching some waves and Ally because I'm
trying to learn how to serve my friends
are all rebel disease and that's bad
it's a curse
[Music]
by looking wondering
because account but my mom is a nurse
it's the word dude I told you we should
hit him harder chill out I have a
duplicate we still got the babes that's
sick dude you're not helping our gimmick
here seriously
heinous catch you later team top five
[Applause]
you
how long was I know a couple minutes I
think it was dreaming about what
[Music]
hitting the waves because I'm learning
surf game learning to surf in the ocean
fall off my board because I'm learning
Serbian learning to surf and it's
hurting my friends I have a phantom pain
[Music]
you